bald komplett sind aber unsere witze
reingelaufen leute herzlich willkommen
zum kontakt wollte am sonntag
wir befinden uns hier gerade auf einem
spielplatz und zwar so dass darunter
gefallen es hat geschneit bei uns ich
weiß nicht ob es bei euch auch
geschnallt hat wo ihr wohnt aber bei uns
ich mache mal ein bisschen so bei uns
hat als bisschen geschneit bisschen
bisschen bisschen geschnallt sieht man
nicht so aber hier schon ich schon
ordentlich was ein staat bekommen und
ich habe gedacht ich war eigentlich erst
ein video darüber machen dass es so eine
studie rausgekommen dass zocker
irgendwie bessere träume haben dass sie
mehr kreativität in den träumen
darüber wollte erst quatschen dass eine
familie gerade gucken wir aber da hab
ich mir dann gedacht dass es doch ihnen
ein bisschen dorf deswegen ich gehe raus
in die natur ein bisschen komisch welche
leute sehen und so ich gehe lieber mal
ein bisschen raus in die natur stellen
daher so ein bisschen rum
lenders länder und letztlich die ganze
matsche pampe das ist eigentlich also
ich bin den rücken kumpel und wir gehen
hier als sonst mal hinsieht mega
schilder aus dahin so richtig wesentlich
es hat geschneit meine damen und herren
hier befinde mich gerade ist und schon
ein kleiner spielplatz in seiner
siedlung uns in der nähe
es hat geschneit mein arm tut weh und
ich weiß gar nicht mehr was jetzt reden
soll kommt eigentlich relativ spontan
ich war gestern um 5 erst im bett
deswegen kommt das ganze jetzt auch ein
bisschen verspätet
die andere hand ich hoffe dass es
trotzdem recht für euch ich hoffe auch
man versteht mich überhaupt gut und
sonst sieht man gar nicht
wenn ich nicht aber es sieht echt mega
stelle ich erstmal fast einmal ganz kurz
hier auflaufen
er macht da hinten safety einfach von
von der schaukel will jetzt hier oben in
dem klettergerüst drin
hocke hier gerade hier grad und wir
werden jetzt gleich noch denke ich
einfach so richtig gern spazieren gehen
ich bin morgen hundertprozentig krank
das kann ich schwören ja gut dass wie
gefällt euch das wenn ich das eigentlich
ist so was was für ein zweit kanal für
luca filmt aber ich dachte jetzt kontakt
hieß das bisschen draußen rumlaufen es
ganz still ich jetzt heute kam mir eine
folge mit den euro kommt morgen noch
eine folge danach wollte ich mit simon
mal wieder ein bisschen was aufnehmen
noch ein paar monaten in dem wir nichts
aufgenommen haben und dann kommen halt
noch ein paar videos über die woche
verteilt ich denke auch mal wieder ein
bisschen aber ich hoffe ich komme runter
ohne dass ich irgendwie aufs maul viel
über die woche verteilt ein paar videos
pvp panrod reviews so was alles alter
mann kennen die zur freude
ich würde sagen wenn ich es schaffen
kann ich ja gleich noch ein bisschen was
dran hängen einfach irgendwie wenn wir
dann
wenn wir irgendwie als nicht wo wir noch
hingehen zur bank und burger king und
sodann kann ich euch einfach mitnehmen
und sonst ist das keine woche zusammen
fast in diesem kontakt sondern eher eine
vormittags zusammenfassung na gut ich
werde ziemlich den kompletten schnee
gelaufen da war ich gerade da oben drin
war und soll bis gleich leute jetzt
befinde ich mich gerade auf dem fahrrad
wir fahren jetzt nämlich im stadtsaal
geld nie mit mir und die bäume geben uns
die ganze zeit die die teilen die ganze
zeit ausgelassen ist schneeflocken
kanonen runterfallen auf unsere bein an
diesen sechster teilnehmer gut gefahren
jetzt im high speed tempo jeder vorne
weil schneller kann man ja einfach nicht
fahren weil hier so richtig fette
pfützen und richtig matschig und eklig
naja wir gehen jetzt bei uns hier in den
wald wenn dann ein bisschen nicht
rumlaufen ist ein fax verschieben leute
verarschen keine und sonst die
landschaft sieht echtes nicht mega geil
aus ich sehe mir ja fertig aus aber die
landschaft sieht mégane eis aus ich weiß
nicht liebe schnee mit schnee sieht
ihnen wie alle schön aus selbst fabriken
können damit schön aussehen war vom
jugendamt ins nämlich fallen so schnell
wieder runter
naja gut freunde ich indem ich jetzt
einfach gleich mit wenn ich gleich mit
dem wald bin und danach waren wir dann
volksbank und burger king und vorne hat
mir gegeben ich bin jetzt hier weiterhin
wegen glaub jetzt hatte ich den wald ihr
seht schon das ist megageil hiervon das
ist echt 30
schnee ist ich schöne sache wir laufen
jetzt ein bisschen rum ich hab meinen
schal verloren deswegen muss man ja kein
bistum hinzuziehen bisschen laufen jetzt
die ein bisschen weit herum
dieser kontakt hat einfach überhaupt no
sense blog meine batterie ist fast
gleich immer noch 20 prozent ist auf
jeden fall geld ja noch mal die schöne
schattenseiten des schnees macho aber
gut aber gut gelaufen jetzt ein bisschen
weit herum und gleich wieder komplett
ist unsere witze rhein gelaufen
aber gut war junge warum sind die lange
laufen man glücklich das mal anders ist
abartig auf eine entscheidung
ein bisschen zurück jetzt laufe wieder
zurück und gleich wenn wir bei burger
king sind kann ich ja auch noch ein
bisschen film und max werden wir
wahrscheinlich auch noch abdecken
und jetzt wo wir sind jetzt hier noch
volksbank hier wird ja ein wenig
geld ab das schönste kommt jetzt eine
rein ist jetzt hier schönen ihr tutorial
härte vor ihre karte reinstecken so als
wäre der automat aus wohnungen
natürlich brauchen noch ein bisschen
geld wenn man gewisse konzeptionelle
ausrichtung geben möchte ich brauche
eigentlich so minimal
ein geräusch des geldes
napoli rote nase unternehmens ihre karte
jetzt können wir in der zwischenzeit
steuerinspektor einstecken
jetzt kann man das geld nehmen derzeit
weiter
bauarbeiter zugange sind jetzt bei
burger king
was hast du dir geholt
die kinder holt eine große coup mit
joghurtdressing meinen pappel steakhouse
des doppeldeckers steht muss den kopf
heben halben bekommen graf steakhouse
weingut freunde also wir sind jetzt bei
burger king
was ist uns jetzt schon schmecken ich
bin total fertig eigentlich jeder fertig
seine leiche
wir essen dass der schirm und dann ich
bin immer so ganz kurz so richtig
schlecht beleuchtet und dann film ich
euch gleich nochmal schönenberger
aussieht und geben wir euch danach eine
empfehlung und wir fallen weil ich
wahrscheinlich auch noch zu merkels
schönes eis schlürfen erfolgreicher
sonntag der bürger aus eigentlich ganz
in ordnung
dabei sieht man schon
bei maxon jedoch nicht mehr weil wir
haben gedacht dass wir zum eckes fahren
wenn über merkels besser chillen kann
und sich da auch cooler als sachen holen
konnte mich freuen ihm zu aber dass uns
auch gefallen mcus hattinger can
macquarie jung mehr deswegen sind wir
einfach anders als bei burger king
genommen bei burger king ziemlich zur u6
nämlich max azria als keine ahnung aber
das war auf jeden fall megageil wegen
sind wir dann einfach noch geblieben
wäre es gerade nach hause gefahren habe
jetzt gerade hier gesehen dass hier auch
schon online ist und jetzt muss ich noch
üben den kontakt 16 250 und freunde
ich weiß nicht einfach mal eine positive
bewertung ab beziehungsweise bewertet
das video wie sonstwas bitte jeder der
jetzt an dieser stelle ist bitter aber
das video bewerten ob ich auch so was
gefällt ja oder nein nicht was euch ein
bisschen mitnehmen so keinen sinn aber
einfach so mitnehmen
dessen leben